there you go welcome back everybody
ladies and gentlemen my next guest is a
comedian and an actress you know from
her six season on Saturday Night Live
she's also author of the book whoops I'm
awesome please welcome to the Late Show
Melissa
[Applause]
[Music]
vior hello
Y no please no please no no no no no no
thank you very much hey so lovely to
have you on thanks for having my
pleasure such an honor to be here guys
yeah honor to have you you just had a
birthday that's a great thing you just
had a birthday a couple days ago happy
birthday says there say 36 oh you wrot I
wrote it down yeah they told you they
told me 36 wow it's true was it a secret
I'm was not supposed to I don't okay
good let know yeah that's why I let my
the gray grow I want let it let it show
it's very distinguished it's I feel cool
yeah it is very cool yeah it's like a
little Bonnie rate yeah yeah it was
lowkey this year but I've had big you
know I've had big birthdays especially
when I was at SNL uh you that what this
is yeah I wanted to show you guys there
was one year when I right one yeah it
was my birthday uh on the SNL taping
when Kim Kardashian hosted and uh I met
her
and um I took a photo with her and you
know she's saying me happy birthday
which is like so who gets that from a
Kardashian you know and she she was like
happy birthday and it was so interesting
cuz at that a beautiful voice happy
birthday to I'm just guessing that's but
um I went to Afterparty and she had a
box of donuts there next to her for some
reason I got really excited for the
donuts poor
I see Kim but I was like oh Kim are
these your donuts and uh and she goes
yeah you can have them so I took them I
ate them they're really good uh she
didn't want them so the photo I have I'm
still holding the
donut you've been on a stand-up tour for
the past six months it is called the new
things tour yeah why the new things
because it was it's a new chapter it was
on SNL for six seasons which is amazing
I'm proud of myself sure and did that
just fly
it did yeah yeah but I I felt like um
this whole past year I've been writing
this is a new hour and it's all about
what do you do after the big The Big
Goal I didn't have any other
plans so I don't so it's all about
reflecting on how amazing I was I got to
do the Impressions that I've been doing
for a long time sure to the celebrities
to their face you know and some of them
liked it some didn't uh Natalie Portman
loved it
she was like wow thank you so much no
one's no one's ever imitated me before
that's
amazing uh she was like I and she really
said I I really thought I was I just
thought I was boring I thought I I I
thought I had nothing unique about my
voice and I was like what's that Natalie
I fell asleep what' you say I thought it
was
boring uh who did may I ask who didn't
or is that too sensitive of no no I mean
uh well no Owen Wilson I've been doing a
long time okay that voice a long I sound
like him because of the years um but
it's stuck after a while yeah and I I
did approach him and I said Owen let's
do the Owens together what do you think
and he got sensitive and he was just but
that's so Owen you know he was like he
was like you know know I thought about
it you know but like I feel like people
are tired people are tired of the Owen
and the wow videos they're tired and I
was like I'm not tired I need
[Applause]
this so it's six years that's quite an
achievement I mean I I worked for SNL
for one month and I was so exhausted I
thought I would die and how did you like
what when do you know it's time to move
on I just felt it I felt like I couldn't
do another year I think it was just I
just listened to myself I think it was
it was getting a lot and do you know how
I knew when it was time for me to move
on how they said no we won't hire
you no yeah yeah I'm not jealous of you
at all this isn't awkward in anyway at
all you've also done a lot of uh art
since have you always done it or is this
a new thing I mean in high school when I
was a little punk I was I was doodling
on the corners of paper but but but
these days it's it's been flowing out of
me and I just I just listen it skeletons
at a campfire I sing along yeah
beautiful it's really is a sweet one I
feel like cuz it's I they're dead but
they're still having fun but I mean it's
hopeful no it is cuz it's it's all that
matters is the Gathering and laughing
right that's all that matters dead or
alive and
and and and the little ones are the
stars are the ones that pass that are
still joining oh it's a deep one guys
they're
deep you also and I already have this
book I also I really like this book it's
called Uh whoops I'm awesome and I'm
just curious where that title came from
because it feels it feels cool to see oh
whoops guess I'm awesome it's just it's
a cool delivery are you doing any
singing These Days yeah I have new
comedy songs I've been sharing on stage
could you would you share one yeah I
want to sh I plan
this I I'm gonna get my friend Louis
over here to join me okay so this song I
wrote um It's kind I sing it in that
folky girl voice that we all hear in the
fall to the season you know the girls
that are like you broke my heart what am
I supposed to do you know those girls
and you're you're like you're going to
be fine you're hot you know so I'm going
to sing it like one of those chicks um I
sing one like one of those ladies and uh
I wrote it about how I I take these
corny solo trips by myself to reconnect
with my creativity and nature and I've
gone to the woods several times and
every single time I get there and I'm
mad I'm like why' I do this this sucks
I'm alone there's no service it's scary
so the song is called solo trip uh I'll
give you a little sneak peek all
right I got to get away from the
city
the noise in the traffic lights make me
dizzy I'm such a fragile girl you see
got to be with the earth and the trees I
got a key to an
Airbnb I see big giant love stains all
over the
sheets not a soul inside no one to call
for help at night and soon I
realize I'll probably be I'll probably
be murdered
tonight
oh murder
[Music]
no thank you so lovely fissa beia Senor
everybody we'll be right back
[Music]